gentlemen thank you so much for joining
us gerald or start with you obviously
this is something that scares everybody
when you hear a report like this how
serious is this threat well I think it's
I think it's very important to
understand that we are talking about the
potential for this kind of intrusion to
occur rather than saying that this is an
imminent threat because FAA is is in
fact taking precautions but we're
talking about the future as more and
more aircraft become more internet
dependent so how exactly does it work
it's basically if if the planes on cap
and Wi-Fi the passenger Wi-Fi is
connected to the cockpit system that's
where you see the vulnerability well as
we described in the report the the
example that we gave is that in the
cabin passengers have broadband
available to them they can upload a
program onto their computer if that
program has malicious software in it and
and again this is important if in fact
the the IP connection on the airport is
connect is able to connect with the with
the cabin and and the avionics then you
have that possibility right now what
happens is that there are firewalls that
prevent that kind of incident occurring
but keeping in mind that firewalls are
software to and up today up to date FAA
has only some special rules for
preventing this kind of thing we're
pointing to the fact that you know ten
years from now when maybe sixty seventy
percent of the fleet will be like the
new aircraft that we see today in terms
of the Dreamliner or the a350 then there
needs to be regulations and standards so
that this does not become a special
condition mark you guys are the Chertoff
group are constantly examining threats
like this how concerned are you about
something like this how easy is this
really to do well I agree with dr.
Dillingham
the big issue is as a security
professionals we're concerned about
technology touching each other so
obviously there's a great concern when
you think about the avionics of an
airframe or the communications of an air
of an airplane being able to touch the
same Wi-Fi or entertainment systems on
that the in flight passengers use and
you know as dr. Dillon said the while
there may be protected with firewalls or
other security control devices those
devices are regularly defeated by bad
guys so we have to get better about
thinking about building security into
these controls at the bet that begin at
the design phase and you know I posit
that that building security into the
design of an aircraft is just as
important as building safety and
efficiency features into the aircraft
the world has changed it now and and as
things are more and more ip-enabled we
have to think about this from a security
perspective just as much as a safety
perspective okay planes that could be
affected the Boeing 787 Dreamliner
Airbus a350 and a380 Gerald what
percentage of commercial aircraft are we
talking about here I read somewhere that
its planes planes newer than 20 years
old aren't most planes newer than 20
years old no I wouldn't go we don't we
don't have a count and I wouldn't say
that most planes are newer than 20 years
old I would say that the fleet is being
renewed and that it is it is the what's
important now is as was said to build in
security and and to build in cyber and
that is what we were talking about the
older fleet had much more separate you
know controls between and not as many
points of potential contact across the
the systems so you know like a third or
those are sort of ip-based but going
forward it'll be fifty sixty percent by
the end of the decade
that was the point of our report is not
to cause concern among the flying public
that this was an imminent danger as such
but to point out that cyber cyber
security challenges changed every day
and FAA must in fact not only Bills
Bills secure the end make sure that the
manufacturers bill secured the end but
constantly be monitoring yet because the
threat changes every day and and you
need to be one step ahead and that was
the basic point of our report still in
the worst case you're saying that a
hacker could commandeer the warning and
navigation systems mark you know the
worst case scenario could a hacker bring
a plane down could a hacker fly a plane
into a building well that that certainly
is a worst-case scenario and you know I
don't think anyone is predicting that
but that's certainly the concern that we
have is that is that we need to keep the
controls separate the the systems
separate so that so that that potential
does not exist and you know that when
you think about this when you have a
Wi-Fi network connected on an aircraft
it's just like a Wi-Fi network connected
anywhere else and you know you could
have potentially have bad guys on an
airplane that could compromise the Wi-Fi
network on the airplane itself so
keeping these you know segmenting these
networks networks is incredibly
important and you know I I know that the
the the manufacturers are thinking about
this but we need more people both both
in the in the airframe manufacturing and
the FAA and then the government
organizations that can think like bad
guys and think about how bad guys would
would seek to you know to circumvent
these security controls